[Music]
sitting here with Mitt Romney's five
sons and just in case anyone's concerned
we don't have enough we do have three
extra Romney's on backup that can be
brought in at any time the sweater vest
is a nice touch yeah that's
tragg lag and Bernie right there just
making up names one of you spotted them
on the way and we just thought we'll
just have these guys we can always bring
them in if you need to and one of you
guys spotted them when you're in the
green room and you said we know exactly
what that is quite awkward Matt you were
talking about pranks and I want to make
sure I get this during the primaries
your dad very interested in getting the
endorsement of Governor Schwarzenegger
and you actually had a device it's a box
that gives you Arnold Schwarzenegger
voice and you used it Matt to play a
prank on thank you I looked at you John
look at the name tag yeah no the other
guy you know the other guy you use it to
play a prank on your dad that actually
seems pretty mean and we have have the
footage here let's take a look
governor Mitt Romney how are you hi how
are you I'm just fine governor how are
you doing today good good
what can I do for you we'll ask you a
bunch of questions they want to have
them answered immediately go right ahead
and shoot who is your daddy and what
does he do
[Applause]
nothing cleanses the mind of a bad prank
than biting into a giant sandwich Matt
was he irritated because he was after
that for a few months I was fearing
retribution I really was but he still
hasn't gotten me focused thanks for the
reminder though thanks he'll come back
what could he do to you to get to know
more about your father I prepared some
true or false questions we have these
two or false questions about your father
true or false your dad can moonwalk I
heard that that's true but we haven't
seen it so we can't is anyone here I
have never witnessed that well wait
because you people are telling you your
dad can move up if someone told me my
dad could moonwalk I would find out
immediately it's over and he's got like
turf toe or something or plaintiff at
plantar fasciitis so it's it's no longer
pause so is he claiming that he once
could it's probably the claim okay but
no one's ever seen you'll have to get
him on here and try it out don't you
think okay true or false your dad went
to college on a croquet scholarship you
need to tell people that's not true I
didn't know
no false candles okay false very good
the campaigns what see deny that true or
false your dad loves to sing true and
what does he like to sing give me an
example of a song he loves to sing he
wants to sing whatever comes to his head
he likes Roy Orbison in particular but
he'll sing whatever you know he had
Farrell's get stuck in his head for
about five years there was a you know
the Will Ferrell's cheerleaders get that
yeah of course yeah so they had they
were at a swim meet and they you know
we're cheering for the swimmers and
there was the taco burrito something's
coming out of your speedo he anytime you
mention would sing that anytime you
mentioned that word taco or burrito you
knew my dad would chime in and then
immediately moonwalking backwards okay
true or false your dad's hair is
chiseled out of imported African
mahogany that is true true at home this
is true or false question home some of
you like to call your dad the mid ster
false
I just tweet I just I call them that
sometimes when I tweet about him okay
true or false when your dad's feeling
under the weather you called el tech
support to talk about that